LOUIS GRAY: Welcome
to Google Developers
weekly for November 11, 2013.
I'm Louis Gray, and this
is our highlight reel
of what's happening in
the world with Google
Developers on the set and off.
We like to start off
each week with insight
from our wise Root Access team.
This week, Don Dodge takes
on the tough question
of how you can negotiate
with potential investors,
and how you can
mitigate risk when
bringing on co-founders
as you get started.
And is it more
likely for a start
up to succeed if the founders
have a proven track record?
What do you do if you
find another start up
with a very similar idea?
Watch as Don tackles
these questions
in our second episode of
Root Access for the week.
And from New York, resident
player and YouTube Player API
expert Ikai Lan shows us how he
uses JSFiddle, an online editor
for rapid JavaScript
iteration and collaboration
with the Player API.
Going further east across
the Atlantic Ocean,
we find ourselves in Paris
for two events focused
on the Cloud.
First, William Vambenepe
delivers an overview
of Google Cloud
Platform en Francais.
Then Ludo Champenois catches up
the French-speaking developers
among us on the latest news
around Google App Engine.
Back here in Mountain View,
Google Analytics analyzer Pete
Frisella provided an overview
to the latest changes
and new features available
on the GA platform.
He walks us through version two
of the dimensions and metrics
tool, changes in the core
reporting API, and more.
In Android land, the launch
of Android 4.4 KitKat
has also brought us a
new array of DevBytes.
Check out
developers.google.com/live/android
to indulge your developers sweet
tooth on closed captioning,
transitions, or immersive
mode, and getting up to speed
on the new storage
access framework.
Now that I've got
KitKat on my Nexus 5,
there's no other phone
that I want to use.
It's great stuff.
And if you want your pages to
render faster without having
to do any work yourself-- and
who doesn't-- you can find
the latest news on Page
Speed, our tools for measuring
and optimizing your site,
in a blog post on Thursday.
And sticking with
Page Speed, there's
now an easier way for
Google Analytics users
to see what's happening
with Page Speed.
You can now see integrated Page
Speed scores and suggestions
right in Analytics, where you
probably spend a lot of time
anyway.
And finally, last
week saw the launch
of a new version of the
Google mobile ads STK for iOS.
There are plenty of
juicy new features,
including support for
64-bit architectures,
greatly reduced library size,
and the inevitable bug fixes.
And to make sure you
never miss any bug fixes,
or a thing from the world
of Google Developers,
subscribe to Google
Developers on YouTube.
And check out the GDL schedule
at developers.google.com/live.
I'm Louis Gray.
And I'll see you in the studio.